those days were different there weren't  so many rules no I didn't go to action  park I wish I would have went to action  park I saw the 14 minute documentary I  was just blown away it just the complete  Lord of the Flies anarchy that went on  there and how all the people that are  grown up now look back on it is one of  the greatest things that in their life I  know it was pretty chaotic but it was  sweet how much they loved  [Music]  just here fine at one point I broke my  orbital laminate and I had a blowout  fracture of my left eye and my left eye  comes out of my head and I had to push  back in let's see what this baby can do  [Music]  don't again that got to me a little  because they I couldn't blow my nose for  six weeks and I couldn't sneeze  [Music]  I still do get a rush it's fun but I do  realize that I've used up most if not  all of my nine lives you can only take  so many chances and I realize that  [Music]  [Music]  you